[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada al día
analizamos las implicaciones del misil
que impactó en suelo polaco causando la
muerte de dos personas tras la polémica
el gobierno polaco podría permitir
entonces que expertos ucranianos accedan
al sitio donde cayó este misil el
presidente el presidente ucraniano
insiste en que no hay ninguna duda de
que no fue un misil de su país el que
cayó en Polonia sin embargo tanto Rusia
como lo están y la propia Polonia
aseguran que este cohete habría sido
lanzado por la defensa aérea ucraniana
por lo que Polonia dio marcha atrás en
sus planes de activar el artículo 4 de
la otana
el presidente Andrés duda lo veo
gestiones a que los observadores
ucranianos participen en la
investigación pero debe cumplir con los
procedimientos y estar de acuerdo con
nuestros aliados
un poco de contexto y saludamos a
alessia Liz Java ella es doctora en
ciencias a políticas y licenciada en
derecho internacional alessia Gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
América de Francia 24 está mañana de
jueves hay una pregunta no que me surge
ante toda esta polémica porque el
presidente ucraniano Bolivia selenski
sigue insistiendo en que no se trata de
un misil ucraniano a pesar que la
evidencia sugiere lo contrario cuando
Estados Unidos también eh Pues dijo que
este misiles podría ser entonces de las
fuerzas ucranianas Polonia Ya dijo que
no se trataría un misil Ruso sino
ucraniano porque la insistencia es el
ensque
Hola buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación Yo creo que es muy importante
saber cuáles son los objetivos a corto y
a medio plazo de los actores implicados
por las declaraciones que hizo byden que
hizo Rusia y que al final tenía que
hacer la otra y y otros aliados pues
está claro que nadie quiere escalada de
la Guerra sin embargo también habíamos Y
observamos últimamente a los ciertos
avances militares y yo está hablando de
personas por parte de Ucrania entonces a
la hora de poder
asegurar un punto de negociación un
punto fuerte
posiblemente Ese es el momento o ese
podría ser a momento para Ucrania cuando
puede tomar una cierta ventaja
sobre sobre las ganancias
claro también Entonces digamos que tras
esto y lo que usted está diciendo buscar
y Ucrania que la otan realmente active
la defensa colectiva tal y como lo ha
señalado también Vladimir Putin que eso
sería como un objetivo del presidente
ucraniano Bolivia Cómo ve cómo ve todo
esto podría ser algún alguna especie de
manipulación
Bueno ya sabemos que durante toda la
historia de la orden pues había había
unas cuantas activaciones del artículo 4
y 5 Solamente una vez Cuatro De hecho se
aplicó y sacudió más bien Turquía con el
asunto de Siria Irak por ejemplo y en el
caso de Polonia también este año
incluido con con sus aliados pero ya
está claro y los polacos Aunque en
principio el Ministerio de asuntos
exteriores polacos han dicho que no
tienen ninguna duda que era misil ruso
Pues el propio presidente a polaco pues
tuvo que ponerse de acuerdo con sus
aliados con byden y con la orden y los
bálticos adicional a que no va a activar
el que que no ha sido el misterio Ruso y
por lo tanto no tiene por el momento la
de activar el artículo 4 por ejemplo
para poder hacer de la orden para poder
hacer las consultas no hay respeto vamos
al otro lado de esta historia al lado
ruso porque recordemos que al principio
pues las miradas estuvieron en Moscú no
acusando digamos a las fuerzas del
kremlin de haber lanzado este este misil
el kremín desde un principio pues se
desligó de estas acusaciones y ahora
pues la evidencia muestra que en efecto
el clemin en este caso específico si
tenía la razón que no fue un misil que
ellos lanzaron a el territorio polaco
Cómo favorecería todo este escenario al
kremlin no en su credibilidad diciéndole
accidente miren que yo sí he tenido la
razón y la evidencia se lo se lo está
mostrando
Bueno hay dos escenarios posibles nadie
quiere escalada y por otra parte pues
Ucrania está buscando también una cierta
ayuda que ya se ve a que la ayuda va a
venir no los estados europeos van a
mandar más la ayuda de defensa en caso
de Rusia como en el caso de Estados
Unidos se han culpado a ambos lados pues
por ser culpables Los Americanos han
dicho que a pesar de lo que no ha sido
el misil ruso a los rusos son culpables
porque ellos han empezado bombardear y
los rusos han dicho que si no había
contrincante porque por parte de los
Estados Unidos esto todo no hubiese
producido para mí está claro que Europa
no quiere la escalada pero los rusos
también quieren sentarse a la
negociación y
a la paz me da impresión que ahora mismo
después bombardeo Y ese es el bombardeo
más fuerte durante el otoño y tampoco
está parado eso es una Clara muestra a
que lo que quieren es sentarse a
negociar algunos puntos
Alicia pero es que alguno me queda claro
digamos Cómo se puede o sea porque Rusia
está haciendo todo esto para negociar a
que porque intensifica estos ataques
ante ante una negociación porque
precisamente hoy también volvió a atacar
a varias ciudades ucranianas sobre todo
en la infraestructura energética no de
cara al invierno entonces no sé si por
ahí van los tiros de Rusia si ustedes no
quieren que yo le siga pues atacando su
infraestructura energética sobre todo de
cara al invierno sentémonos en la mesa
pero como cómo lo ve también occidente y
Ucrania digamos que está complicado el
panorama no sé si nos puede aclarar un
poco Yo pienso que un punto fuerte que
los rusos quieran jugar y por lo menos
lo que están tratando de en sus medios
de comunicación que invierno va a ser
bastante duro es verdad que están
bombardeando a la parte estratégicos de
Ucrania y ese es el hecho pero por otra
parte la situación económica de Rusia
Tampoco tampoco es muy tampoco es muy
buena y ellos han perdido últimamente
gerson O sea no hay logros militares y
este es este año creo que
adquieran de una u otra manera o antes
de nochevieja a pues enseñar Cuáles han
sido los avances en la guerra que ya
está durando casi un año Por eso eso es
importante de alguna manera pues tratar
establecer la paz y si quieres Paz Busca
la guerra Busca las posiciones
ventajosas para poder negociar porque
los ucranianos con el tema de Corazón ya
lo habían tenido y los rusos de una de
esta manera pues lo quieren también a
recuperar Yo pienso que Bueno yo pienso
incluso algunos generales americanos han
dicho que está claro que no puedes sacar
a los rusos de este territorio del
territorio ucraniano por completo y como
los rusos tampoco pueden avanzar por por
invierno por toda la complejidad y ahí
en este escenario Por una parte desde el
punto de vista estratégico ucranianos
pues simplemente tienen una cierta
ventaja si no hablamos de la energía es
precisamente donde los rusos están
tratando de atacar para poder equilibrar
esa situación y más los europeos están
mandando más y más ayuda no le queda
otro remedio a por lo menos al momento
de ahora bueno Esperemos que esa
negociación o llegue pronto no por el
bien sobre todo de las personas civiles
que son los que más han sufrido de esta
guerra